le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
chaque jour de nombreux jeunes
réunionnais des jeunes dans leur
établissement scolaire pour lutter
contre le surpoids et améliorer les
pratiques alimentaires les collectivités
travaillent sur des menus équilibrés et
simple le département gère 83 collèges
sur l'île il a mis en place une
politique de valorisation des produits
locaux qui bénéficie aux producteurs
pays et aux élèves
[Musique]
6 heures du matin alors que le cirque de
salazie s'éveille aux premières lueurs
du jour derrière les cuisines du collège
lacaussade c'est déjà l'effervescence
tous les lundis pierre le chef
réceptionne les livraisons qui vont
approvisionner l'établissement pour la
semaine donc voila et tomates carottes
parlions pomme de terre fraîches défilé
banal d'armande
la pelle mécanique n ya rien à dire
des produits frais cultivés par les
agriculteurs des environs pour eux le
collège est un client fiable et pratique
alors allez-vous l'hégire permirent de
paul
c'est ce qu'on contrôlait avec les
collèges on a 60 ans - 1 % par an pour
les
enfants dire qu'il ya un suivi
ces banques nous
accueille ce matin
là et tout ça c'est bio donc voilà donc
ça on va le mettre tout de suite ça va
servir la dame a préparé pour une pour
midi une fois les produits en stock hier
et avis le munis de la semaine l'ennui
hâtives et où carrie coop et harry grain
appris à prix cassés brède bio donc bio
c'est ce que tu as vu qu'ils arrivent et
ce matin on essaye de faire en sorte que
ok on différencie les menus pour
utiliser qu'ils puissent goûter à tout
après ils goûtent si un patron peut pas
les forcer à manger ce qu'ils donnent
leur fait des épinards à la crème
sevriena dimanche là qui mange pas et
aric haricots verts persian qu'ils
adorent
après des débuts sur paris le chef
rejoint le collège auguste lacaussade en
2005 dans ce cadre naturel travailler
les produits frais locaux est presque
une évidence on essaie de travailler à
90% que visiter des produits frais donc
sur notre administration c'est à dire
monsieur fassi par l'actionnaire sont
tout à fait d'accord aussi pour qu'on
puisse travailler tous les produits
locaux c'est aussi au niveau du conseil
parental c'est ce qu'ils valent aussi
qu'on puisse privilégier les produits
les produits locaux
[Musique]
avec 500 repas à servir par jour
l'établissement va même plus loin ici
les élèves sont sensibilisés au manger
bon bien et responsable on a fait un
travail sur le gaspillage déjà une
espèce d'éducation des enfants auto du
gaspillage l'a montré qu'il fallait
d'abord reprendre ce qu'on était capable
de manger pas prendre pour prendre on a
fait en sorte que ce soit les élèves
même qui autodiscipline
s'autodiscipliner autodiscipline un
petit peu les autres élèves et au fur et
à mesure sont devenus les ambassadeurs
de lutte contre le gaspillage à l'heure
du déjeuner les élèves se servent donc
en connaissance de cause et avec
enthousiasme j'aime bien parce que c'est
très bon s'est équilibré il ya beaucoup
de choix
j'ai trop conséquent je mange quoi
le collège de salazie fait office
d'exemple le département veut accroître
la part de produits locaux dans les
menus des établissements de l'île alors
actuellement nous en sommes à 10 % de
produits locaux qui sont utilisés dans
nos cuisines au sein de nos collèges
objectif pour le département il est
double nous soutenons une filière
agricole et une filière de viande
réunionnais donc une filière de viande
locale afin de ramener du bout dans les
assiettes de nos collégiens mais
également soutenir une activité qui est
ambitieuse et qui est dynamique l'autre
ambition un peu le département c'est de
transmettre à l'ensemble de ces
collégiens ses petits enfants
réunionnais et bien connaître le produit
pays connaître le goût les également se
familiariser davantage avec les fruits
et légumes mais les viandes pays donc
ramené du bon goût dans l'assiette de
nos collégiens pour également leur état
de santé
[Musique]
le département gère 83 que les shows
l'île soit 35000 repas par jour pour
améliorer les pratiques alimentaires et
valoriser la production locale la
collectivité soutien des filières pays
dans la restauration scolaire tout en
maintenant un prix équitable d'une
moyenne d'un euro 97 sparrow pas pour
plus de renseignements vous pouvez vous
rendre sur le site du département au
www.cn.ca 4 point fr
[Musique]
m